[Music]
rabens home has been a huge hit just
like its original version That's So
Raven but Disney has kept some major
secrets from you keep watching to find
out which cast member has a criminal
record can't get enough of all things
Disney Channel be sure to subscribe to
get more secrets and scoops now let's
get to the ten dark secrets about Ravens
home that disk doesn't want you to know
where is Eddie in the original series
Raven had two best friends Chelsey and
Eddie Eddie was hilarious and an amazing
bestie to the two girls he was played by
actor Orlando Brown so why isn't Orlando
Brown in the news series well he has had
a lot of trouble since the show ended in
fact he was just arrested again in June
of 2018 about a month after being
arrested for not making a court date
it's really sad that he's got so many
issues we definitely miss seeing him on
Ravens home and we hope he starts
getting some help
Eddie was recast so if Orlando Brown
can't play Eddie why didn't Disney
Channel just pick a new actor it turns
out they did Orlando Brown made peace
with the decision to be recast because
of where his life is right now in Ravens
home Eddie was supposed to be played by
YouTube star Alonzo LaRon in the
original concept for the show all three
members of the trio were supposed to be
there but Alonzo has not made an
appearance on the new show we aren't
quite sure what happened do you think we
should have a new Eddie or is it better
that Eddie's not on the show since we
can't have Orlando Brown we don't know
but we do missing have all three BFFs
hidden feminist messages Disney Channel
has often shown super traditional
families so it's kind of a big deal to
have a show with two single moms who
live together to make life a little
easier we think it's pretty awesome how
they raise their families together but
this show is definitely showing people
that single moms are strong and can do
an amazing job raising kids we love that
this show is all about strong women in a
non-traditional family who really have a
happy life even when things get
complicated the two moms figure it out
Raven and Chelsea are amazing moms and
awesome best friends to each other
that's us there's no doubt about it
the Ravens home theme song is led it is
absolutely perfect for such an awesome
show and the theme song for that So
Raven was pretty awesome too brave
home does a great job paying tribute to
the original at the end of that so
Ravens theme song Raven would pop up and
say that's me in the new theme song she
says that's us it's a great reference to
the original but also highlights that
the new show is about more than just
Raven love it risky business That's So
Raven was a huge deal when it came on in
2003 it was the first Disney Channel
show to focus on an african-american
family plus it was just an amazing show
it became the longest-running Disney
Channel show back then it's no surprise
that Ravens home takes just as big a
risk as the original by featuring a
non-traditional family and focusing a
lot on the adults it really stands apart
we love that it can appeal to so many
people aren't you glad Disney decided to
take such a huge risk with this hit show
that's so controversial before Ravens
home Raven Symone was on the daytime
talk show The View while she was on
there she was a super controversial host
she made many comments that offended
other African American people she placed
blame on a teenage girl who's dragged
out of her seat by his school Cobb she
made some disbar geing remarks about
unique names and that's just some of the
things she did unfortunately she
alienated a ton of fans at one point
there was even a petition to remove her
from the view while she wasn't fired she
did not stay on the talk-show much
longer a lot of people were glad to see
her go that's a lot of drama but we're
just glad she's back as her favorite
psychic think that's crazy
keep watching to find out which star was
arrested why is Raven divorced the new
show focuses on the lives of Raven and
Chelsea as single moms they don't really
talk about why they are single but Raven
opened up to Seventeen magazine on why
her character is divorced
Raven ended up marrying her high school
love from that so Raven Devin since they
were together so young they just grew up
and grew apart so sad but Ravens right
that happens a lot it was really
important to her that they show divorced
parents who get along
so when Devin makes a guest appearance
their characters totally get along and
that's just awesome for their kids
ravens artistic side not only is Raven
Symone an amazing actress and great
singer she's also an artist she loves to
paint and she's pretty good at it in
fact you can see some of her art hanging
around
set of ravens home awesome she sometimes
even has her art on costumes from the
show you have to look carefully
she likes to challenge her followers to
find her secret art in each episode she
is just so talented it's not even fair
check out her Instagram for more of her
gorgeous art is there anything this diva
can't do adult humour Raven doesn't just
star on her new show she is also the
executive producer and since she wants
the show to appeal to adults as well as
kids she manages to sneak in some adult
humor and innuendos there is definitely
a lot of twerking weed out most kids
pick up on the subtle adult jokes hidden
throughout the series but we bet their
parents do it wouldn't be Disney if they
didn't try to include some inappropriate
jokes in humor but overall Ravens home
is a pretty wholesome TV show criminal
Chelsea Chelsea Ravens hilarious best
friend isn't quite as innocent as she
seems
Anneliese Vanderpol who plays the goofy
redhead once made a really bad decision
and was arrested for it back in 2006 she
drank while driving and hit several cars
that's crazy
she pled guilty and was given three
years of probation she also had to
attend an alcohol education class we
guess she learned her lesson because she
hasn't made the news since then we're
glad she keeps her act under control now
which dark secret shocked you the most
let us know in the comments that's it
for the ten dark secrets about Ravens
home that Disney doesn't want you to
know give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]